five hundred twenty-five thousand six
hundred subscribers plus seventy five
thousand more and that's the subscriber
count we currently have thank you guys
so much for following us we did last
night
hi there recheck nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey as you can see at the
top of this hilarious opening that we
had we hit 600,000 subscribers thank you
guys thank you so if you're new and you
like this video hit the subscribe button
I always find a we're when people say
that at the top of the video it's like
we shouldn't you watch the video first
and then but hey well it'll say it at
the top for this one yeah is we're gonna
watch the honest trailers for Mission
Impossible fall out I was on movie
fights just last week up against Clark
Woolf and Mark and Draco the top
question the main question was who is
the greatest action hero of all time and
I argued for Ethan Hunt franchise epic
voice
[Music]
[Laughter]
together because
[Music]
hey-oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yep scrape a lot of people with quests
that was really funny honest trailers
yeah wonder if their reaction to honest
trailers that like outside of ourselves
always depends on the love that someone
has for the movie do you know what I
mean you ever wonder that like yeah
maybe like depending on how much you
love this movie will affect how much you
laugh at it on this trailer one
especially those trailers that are for
movies that they're not really roasting
that much that are pretty good on their
own over there yeah you know I feel like
a lot of people's favorite on the
trailers might have the potential to be
the ones that are really kind of tearing
the movie apart but sure it is pretty
fun they pointed out some things that I
had not thought about with the Mission
Impossible series well really quick
before we go to our thoughts in this
honest trailer
let's want to say for the first trailer
we did a sketch that we put at the very
top of their reaction to that trailer
and took a lot of hard work so be cool
if you guys go check that out I feel
like honestly really got me was when
they talked about Solomon Lane yeah
they're like if you're thrilled for
Solomon Lane return one of the best bad
guys did come from part five like my
favorite one out of the whole franchise
is Philip Seymour Hoffman but in par
five he was such a fantastic villain and
then he returns for this one I don't
even register like oh yeah that's the
same dude from rogue nation unless you
really remember the hell out of rogue
nation but at the time when I saw the
Fallout trailer I'd only seen rogue
nation one time so I didn't really
remember it and I mean that is the thing
about these movies I feel like the
things you remember the most are Tom
Cruise the ensemble and whatever crazy
stunt sequences they had to do and some
of the finer details you will have to go
back at a Finn hunt being intense is
when they tend to remember yeah which is
why I love Ethan Hunt you know that's
why I has fun reasons I argued for him
you know like another quick 30 seconds
or another start talking other things I
didn't say um he's also very romantic
you know like James Bond is his
misogynistic and
womanizer but he's also very romantic I
really love how in this movie especially
it shows how he really deals with choice
and the consequences of that he's not
the guy who will do that greater a good
sacrifice the greater good you know he
doesn't intentionally doesn't let ving
rhames it's true big really doesn't let
Luthor die even though if we just let
him die he could have solved the mission
right then and there because of that
yeah that's my favorite reason why it's
such a cool hero in terms of like the
characters coming back I thought this
was pretty cool about fallout was
fallout was the first one the other ones
it's it's cool if you see the prior
installments cuz you get little nuggets
throughout the fallout was the first one
that was kind of a tribute to the films
that came prior to it you know like they
hearken all the way back to the first
one tie it in to the third one with
Michelle Monaghan like a rogue nation
they take the villain of that one and
put him in here and I thought that was
cool how this one was sort of you know
like a fan film in a lot of ways for the
other mission impossible' there's a lot
of tributes like bother can be a little
bit of oh yeah who are these characters
names again and then how lot of
characters don't come back but I
actually like that joke that at like a
really cool twist if the apostles were
the guys who are not coming back in the
other one so good and that would be a
perfect send-off get everybody back
together yeah last Tom Cruise Mission
Impossible joy yeah all of his burned
helpers come back for revenge would be
perfect it would make sense to I feel
like it's not too much of a stretch to
lean in that direction you choose to
accept that mission oh man and they all
probably blame Ethan for something the
Henry Cavill bits that were really funny
like the mustache myths we've always
known for a lot of jokes about all the
bathroom bits I didn't even think about
that yeah I'm gonna have a fight scene
at least one's gotta be in a bathroom
I'll be able to take my ships and that
joke about a Hagar from final but that's
so true I think the mission of possible
shows are great especially that first
one for fallout yeah but they do really
give away that Henry Cavill is a bad guy
yeah the movie treats it like it's a
twist yeah because they don't make it
clear until later on in the movie half
the movie is about finding out who the
mole is yeah exactly and to give that
away and the trailer just seems like III
wonder how and why that happened because
it just seems such a weird thing to give
away I think it's because some of the
biggest secret like the helicopter
sequences specifically which is the big
finale stunt fight day you know that's
him going up against Henry Cavill and
you know like with all the effort they
put into that sequence that gotta tease
it in the trailer yes so and so I think
because of that you know to see it cuz
henry cavill did that stunt too he was
really hanging out of a helicopter
firing a gun with real ammunition yeah
he's really doing that stun sound like
all right that makes sense why they
would would tease it the movies are more
about the thrills in the excitement it
would have been nice to not have that
spoiled simultaneously the trailers
really just do give that away hey man I
didn't really paint our enjoyment of the
movement really who's to say yeah that's
the movies good enough it works anyway I
really love this honest trailer fallout
is a film I very much Doradus definitely
on my top 10 list of this year I was one
of the best theater experiences I've
ever had and I still don't consider it
my personal favorite Mission Impossible
movie but I think in terms of an action
movie it's still the best action movie
out of all the Mission Impossible my
favorite ones still the third one but as
an action movie this is the best one in
my mind and yeah go check out my movie
fights guys that was a fun match long
that was a lot of stressful ones I'm
looking for my next one that one's gonna
be tense yeah alright guys well you guys
can subscribe the screen junkies
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to ring it
whatever people say and check us out on
you know stuff patreon Stardust